[Musique]
des milliers d'objets intrigant des
reconstitutions en cire ou en papier
mâché et surtout des organes humains
authentiques comme vous n'en avez jamais
vus et la plupart sont très vieux comme
nous le raconte le directeur de musique
le docteur richard fraser ce que très
spécial c'est un coeur qui prit disons
pas un dû ronde qui était un des
fondateurs de l'université king est
élevé ni d'une patiente et traqueront de
suivi pour une différence cardiaque
et puis quand le patient aimant quand il
avait 22 ans
dr en effet son autopsie retrouver
n'avaient que il indiqué au lieu de dire
que nous avons normal et ça c'est il ya
200 ans exactement
il a fait la tap si dans 1821 cet
immense collection d'organes humains a
donc été constitué au 19è et au début du
20e siècle à des fins pédagogiques pour
les étudiants en médecine des coeur des
poumons des raies sein ou gravement
atteints ont été prélevés à des patients
à une époque où le docteur avait tous
les droits pourquoi c'est impossible à
l'époque parce que les noms étaient
différents quand des médecins fait
notable si par exemple son patient
c'était possible pour lui facilement de
garder de queue
poumon quelque chose comme ça qu
enseigner mondes habités
c'était une femme extraordinaire et
venu à mes yeux en 1898 pour être en
charge du musée
elle est restée là pour vingt cinq ans
est ce sa direction le musée devenu
fameux générique elle en amérique du
nord
et puis de les monter ce avec
l'évolution des technologies d'abord la
photographie puis l'informatique et
l'imagerie 3d
la fonction pédagogique de ces spécimens
a perdu son intérêt des milliers de
pièces hautes accumulé la poussière
pendant des décennies jusqu'à ce que le
docteur fraser décident de fouiller dans
les voûtes de la célèbre institution
c'est incroyable
en clair quand j'ai chanté quand j'ai
commencé j'ai pensé qu'il n'avait que
deux heures centaines peut-être des
spécimens mais j'ai trouvé une grande
chambre où il y avait à peu près 1500
denis puis c'était collectionner
dans les deux sens avant que je trouvais
cette chambre je souhaitais que le
public vienne en plus des étudiants oui
la plus l'objectif aussi oui je pense
que c'est important pour vous
de voir des maladies que
et aussi la content de l'histoire de
médecine en québec et à écrire aussi
[Musique]